when i was considering going to college
my 18 year old self was quite
overwhelmed i wasn't sure what exactly i
wanted in a college and i remember
having a lot of conversations with my
dad because he was the one that first
introduced me to hillsdale my mom went
to hillsdale i heard about hillsdale my
junior year my sister went to hillsdale
really saying to him like no dad i don't
want to college i want a university my
cousins went to hillsdale so i was
absolutely opposed to applying here i
heard the spiel it's a christian college
it's hard it takes no government money
that's what my aunt told me well i
visited and i fell in love pretty fast i
really was drawn by the challenge it
presented i need a different sort of
education different sort of training a
different view on what college should be
i wanted to learn how to be a great
leader to be a great person and
hillsdale through their education
definitely teaches you how to do that
and gives you the tools to make you the
best person that you can be
so i get to interview hillsdale
college's president whom i have not yet
met so
i'm nervous to say the least
[Music]
nice to meet you welcome my senior year
i was faced with a lot of options for
college and to be honest i was very
overwhelmed dr arne very overwhelmed it
was one of the most stressful times of
my life how would you describe
hillsdale's approach to education to a
student considering where they should go
hillsdale college was born in 1844
and it is stuck by what it was founded
to do since the beginning we're
interested in
god and we're interested in character
and
freedom and we're interested in learning
and learning of a very high kind the
classic approach is to
begin by defining things you should get
an idea of what college is regardless
what you want from it
it is something it's overwhelmingly
thought of today as preparation for a
job
and that's a very expensive way to go
about it if it however is thought of as
preparation for a good life
then of course it's worth an infinite
price
and so the arts where we approach that
most directly
are the liberal arts
the core curriculum hillsdale college is
the profound thing
that means it's at the foundation down
at the bottom everything built on that
if you get started in the right way
you'll get farther
and so the liberal arts in the core is
the foundation of everything we do here
good job hi dr calvert
oh so good to see you everybody majors
in something right which is important
but hillsdale is also about making sure
that everybody
understands the place of every
department every area of study that
mathematics and philosophy have a lot to
say to one another
history and the sciences have a lot to
say to one another within the minds and
hearts of our students we want them to
understand that this is a unity this is
a whole
yeah you got to have like a foundation
of multiple things to really appreciate
the specific things that you then study
in earnest
built into the college mission is a
specific focus on the western
intellectual and cultural heritage
truth is the object of that heritage
it's about
realizing our full intellectual moral
spiritual and social political humanity
in the end all those things are going to
be crystallized by being here in a
community
that's that's why this is a partnership
that's why this is a college
we wanted that baby
and isabelle and i we're on our way back
from an utter side run utter side is our
favorite ice cream place in all of
hillsdale we made new friends this is
the most midwest thing
i know it's a small school but you still
meet people really cool people all the
time i think the honor code is the
coolest thing ever everyone is going to
be respectful of each other the
friendships that i've made here at
hillsdale are something that has
changed and transformed my life entirely
but i've gotten some teary looks from my
mom
when i say uh yeah i gotta head back
home but i don't really talk about you
know my home in detroit in dearborn i
talk about my home in hillsdale i never
have felt alone at hillsdale there's
definitely a really strong tight-knit
community that you find here that i
haven't found anywhere else the students
here
all come with the same purpose of being
stretched and challenged in new ways
intellectually emotionally
mentally morally spiritually it makes it
easier to go through it when you have
people walking the same path
[Music]
having and expressing faith in god is
becoming increasingly difficult on
college campuses
and so how does faith fit into the mix
at hillsdale college
this was founded as a christian
institution
the reason god has fallen out of favor
it's because we commit a logical
contradiction commonly and that is that
god is bad
or belief in god is bad whereas
there's no definition in any faith or in
philosophy
in which god is not the perfect being
and since we all seek to make ourselves
better
an idea of a perfect being grows
naturally from that activity
and so to exclude god from a college
campus is to exclude its central purpose
there is nothing serious
nothing consequential nothing certainly
noble
about human beings that isn't infused
with its divine origins if you're going
to be serious about being learned
and about being noble
you're going to be serious about god too
i'm going to be completely honest with
you hillsdale can be really challenging
one of the quotes here the only motto is
strength rejoices in the challenge doing
hard things understanding that's a
chance to become a better person and
better yourself through that work i've
grown so much because of your classes i
definitely
would not be as passionate about econ i
think i connect with people who have
gotten better i have a perspective from
that because i was not a good student
but then i fell in love with economics
and i became a good student and so as a
professor i can see students and see the
potential because i know i lived it
strength really does rejoice it doesn't
put up with the challenge it doesn't
resign itself to a challenge it rejoices
in a challenge
it's a curious thing that the serious
study of the liberal arts is an
excellent training for a job because you
learn things that are fundamental to any
job
when i leave hillsdale my career
ambition is to serve in the united
states army as a translator i would like
to go back home to colombia which is
where i'm originally from and to apply
all these things that i've learned here
at hill so back home i am considering
going on to study bioethics practically
i want to illustrate book illustrations
but then also medical illustration i
want to be able to take the lessons that
i've learned here and to apply them to
the world being humble being kind being
patient listening being all the things
that hills are really nurtures and
develops especially in a world that
really gives that a run for its money
first step is cultivate all the virtues
and they are for courage
moderation justice
and wisdom
work on those every day
in the end
you have to get your soul in order both
the moral and intellectual virtues
and that's ultimately the purpose of
education